hello everybody my name is markiplier
thank you so much for joining me day you
all look lovely okay we were going on a
little adventure here where we're out
and buy this farm and there are a bunch
of wasp and beehives around here that I
don't really want to mess with but then
again I don't really have to so we're
over here in the distance and we got our
things over here I need to make my way
back to chesty over here whatever his
name was baggy baggy mix a curtains and
I can't really recall but I need to get
it because you guys pointed out that I
need to keep the eye bone with me in
order to be able to make him follow me
and he's got a lot of my goodies so I
want to make sure that he stays with me
now you guys also mentioned that um I
can use um what I need to find is I need
to find the pig king the pig king of
sorts he's in forest areas excuse me I'm
trying to play a game here please do not
text me um I'm going the wrong way
actually if this road leads to there nah
it's still faster to take the wormhole
there but I'm just hesitant to go
through the swamp because of the giant
tentacle monsters ah hold it stay away
from me I don't like you okay anyway
there was a road here I probably should
have taken that from the first place
jump in wormhole not a same thing to do
but I have no other choice it is now day
10 of my adventure and things aren't
going too well for me I mean I've got a
lot of materials but you guys informed
me that on day 20 there's going to be a
giant winter storm of sorts that is
gonna make me rue the day that I ever
came here and I am apologetic in that
short because I have not been exactly
preparing but I need to go get chesty in
order to do things actually now that I'm
thinking about it let's see there are
only a certain number of areas that I
have not explored this all area here is
a peninsula but down here there's more
however by that farm in order to find
the pig king basically I have to explore
a lot more I'm gonna keep chesty with me
but man that's a lot of rabbits I wish I
could eat them right now but can I do
that I had to cook up my berries just
because they were getting kind of stale
and they're gonna help keep my health up
because when you cook things
that helps keep your health up a little
better anyway what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go up here and get chessy and then
I'm gonna go back down and try to keep
exploring in the new area that I went to
which means that I probably should
disassemble these guys here
Chester thank you come here come here
boy come here boy I hope you're doing
well and not gonna die anyway I wanted
to make sure um one last thing I don't
know if I should take these with me
because I could disassemble these with
the hammer but I don't have rope with me
I mean I could make rope no problem see
dear yeah I should probably break these
down just to get some components from
them or keep them here or leave them
here I'm not really sure which is the
best option at this point
but either way let me take this backpack
and drop them in a whoops no no no no
don't do that give me that back excuse
me thank you
okay so as soon as I pick up that
backpack I immediately put it on so
that's a problem huh um I guess I guess
I don't need it right now
which means that I can just scare them
okay come here Chetty yamir just go
there buddy come here boy all right a
tenth of my misadventure I'm still at a
loss of why I got here or how but they
need to find a way out immediately and
apparently the beard does not make you
go insane the beard the beard where did
where the hell am I gonna beard keeps
you warm in the winter which is a good
thing very very good thing ah that's a
wolf not again do not kill Chester I
will murder you if you kill Chester you
know what I could probably take you but
I don't wanna right now because we're in
Chester come here boy hurry up Chester
hurry up oh we're going the wrong way
Chaz are come by they eyes you can't get
me you think you can get me damn Wolfman
that's my buddy my buddy or tri yeah
suck on that if someone said you
doughnut you do not eat the monster me
what I'm gonna do this backpack has been
more trouble than it's worth I'm just
gonna let it lie
suck on that wolf how dare you attack
Chester he's my only friend in this
place
he's the only thing that's keeping me
any sort of sane look at this poor bloke
nose out hey blue cuz I'm Martin this
man is a gentleman over England a little
land England land of sorts London land
my good friends over in Britannia
alright whatever let's hop on over grab
these seeds don't attack the bees cuz
that would be a bad idea
go Manchester just ah follow me into the
world
so when hole we go that was not a sane
thing to do you will be alright
Chester thank you follow me to our new
home
whoa what is that that was a guy in the
beginning hang on let's explore this it
really captures his personality so who
is that guy you think you could use that
what do you need the mining bit we don't
have much time now but there's a lot of
graves to dig up here we could get some
nightmare fuel for a couple more
advanced thing he's okay where's the
road I'd screw it we're just going past
it mmm I do not like walking through the
marsh at night so let's please get back
onto the road I think I'm on it I can
barely see there we go that's a little
better come on Chester we got a place to
go for the night to get all this gold
later but right now I need to reset up
some science machines and advanced
building machines and all sort of stuff
like that because this is gonna be our
new home base and then Chester
there you are I didn't know if that
noise was didn't know if you died on me
I don't know what I'd do if you died
Chester you're my only friend here all
right I only have leaves to use for
fuels good time no don't eat them
what are you doing that you're eating
these spoiled leaves when you have
plenty of food else
okay anyway the seeds are starting to
grow and I need to just eat them no not
those eat the berries the berries are
starting to good the berries are
trending baby
God it's growing so slowly there's
probably a way to make it grow faster
with like manure or something but I'm
not exactly sure I need wood I can't
believe I don't have any wood okay there
aren't even really any trees around here
I gotta go south with them trees before
it gets night but it's already starting
to get night I might be in trouble just
just chop them down quickly we gots to
go Chester things aren't looking so good
buddy let's get - get back at the stump
might as well dig it out
goodie all right switch that up fast as
you please all right someone warned me
that if I chop a certain tree a giant
monster will pop out so I need to be
careful about that I don't exactly know
how I'm supposed to know what it what
the wrong tree is but hopefully it will
tell me okay um I don't need to find
Joni it's just planted ah piss it's
nighttime gotta get back gotta get back
uh uh it's dark is that the full moon
someone told me the full moon is bad oh
I can see it's beautiful
this isn't burn all these leaves
hopefully the fire won't touch to my
crops up there the night isn't very long
so we're just gonna do a few things
while we're here we need to build the
science machine gonna put it right yeah
there are flour flies all over the place
that I could catch but I don't really
have anything that I could do with them
okay straw roll sleep through the night
I don't want to do that just yet because
when I wake up from sleeping through the
night it gets makes me very hungry um
god I do have enough stuff here Chester
come here come here why I'm gonna give
you something
ah good lordy I have too much crap ah
man what is with uh I need to trade you
guys told me that I could trade this
stuff with the pig king and he would be
able to give me other stuff but as far
as I'm doing right now
I don't even know where the picking is
so what I need to do is I need to make
some progress
like right meow right meow I need to
make some progress
so let's venture house south and start
exploring chests ah you're giving good
boy follow me I will not lead you stray
not lead you astray I need to eat use
carefully go back all right and carrots
apparently do give you a bit of help oh
do not tell me that I'm gonna reach the
edge of the ocean here I need to find
something my whole life is being a lie
I'm gonna pick the berries on me always
look out for more food because winter is
coming oh no no no no this is impossible
can't be another Peninsula I'm gonna
have to go through the forest of wasps
to try to find something else huh this
is my life this is my life waiting out
here chest ah I don't know what I'm
going to be able to do it's all a very
depressing scenario isn't it Chester
because I'm headed straight for the
marsh and if another place doesn't turn
south I'm in for a world nope
my life is a lie we're stuck in Chester
we're going to have to venture north
hopefully there will be an area north
that we can go I do not want to resort
to picking the graves again we all know
how that turned out just ah right Jessa
Chester you're not responding to me
Chester oh this cuz your mouth is full
chest up ha ha ha ha ha
I forgot that you had many things
stuffed in your face hole ok anyway
we're gonna venture north and then we're
gonna go and find this damnable oh man
my sanity is just starting go I need to
pick me some daisies lovely flowers
these they will do my sanity good
oh no another ocean
what Rochester we're gonna die Chester
design wasps retire Chester save
yourself the sermon examinable wasps aah
they're everywhere chatter please
protect me not the bees are coming after
me - do not kill Chester I will die for
Chester all right looks like they've
given up the chase ah this is what I'm
looking for all right there's a new
connecting bar oh that's scared I
thought it was gonna be the big tree mas
ha ha ha aah aah scared me how dare you
startle me like that who's that
suspicious dirt piles animal track uh-oh
some sort of animal wolves maybe they
have sir be some wolves that are trying
to nibble on my giblets but they know
that they cannot tangle with me and far
too tenacious Garrett's good me some
flowers good looking for a sort of pig
like king I'm really glad that this
started to go all the way up here what
is that
Maxwell's door you are about to step
into a long arduous journey to find
Maxwell you will need to survive five
worlds each randomly generated to
present a new challenge should you die
you will start back at this portal but
lose all your progress on the journey
holy crap this is what you guys were
telling me about this is the door I
found Maxwell's door this means that I
can start the journey into adventure
mode this is incredible guys Wow
I'm not ready to go in it just yet I
need to prepare a bit more I will
obviously take Chester with me but I
would prefer to find the pig king first
and then be able to do that of course
depicting like being one of the randomly
generated worlds beyond the way but how
let me think about this let me think
about what I'm gonna do I've got a good
bit of food here I've got a spear and
I've got Chester with all his stuff I
mean really I'm kind of in the best
situation to go that I could possibly be
I mean I've got this tools to make new
science machines I could obviously get
new stuff
you know what let's go for it I want to
see because if I die in there
I'll lose all my stuff but I'll just
wind up back here and my farm is just
down the way so in all in all I'm pretty
well prepared to go and it's almost
nighttime so let's go for it
let's go for it let's go for it let's go
into there let's do that Maxwell I'm
coming for you or to go home let's do
this ah just ah follow me
good I'm beginning trees hurting buckets
and buckets insinuating food chapter 105
the game is afoot so now we're
officially oh hello oh no is it winter
found my portal did he you'd think you'd
have learned your lesson by now let's
try something a little more challenging
show oh no did it start me out with
nothingness divining I found a divining
rod let's see there's a chest here ah so
at least Chester did not equip me with
nothing else it's winter now so
obviously this winter hat will help but
I need to start finding stuff right away
no time to waste need to find some Flint
to make an axe
these trees don't look good but it's the
best I can do right now oh wait I
already have some Flint cook up an axe
cuz we're gonna need wood more than
anything
top yep don't know oh so much wood down
the hall birds laughing me I don't even
have my beard anymore and the evening
apparently lasts about 10,000 hours now
which is not a good thing or anyway
let's just keep chopping we got to make
sure that we last through the night in
the night is long the day is very short
this is survival at its utmost all right
we got wood I need to find food before
it gets dark but they don't know we're
up where the hell I'm gonna find any I
don't know berry bushes spawn the same
way they do during the night so or
during the summer I might be in for a
world of hurt here only got one carat
one carat getting laid it's not getting
late berry bush
excellent most excellent no damnable
spiders you think that you can tangle
with me I've survived far worse
situations than you this will not prove
to be a challenge I will survive like my
forefathers before me here
oh yeah Maxwell's silver hammer I don't
know what my last name is sir it will be
silver hammer
I am regrettable that chesty is gone I
should have gone for the pig King
beforehand but who knows how long it
would have taken me is that a green
mushroom three mushrooms are good these
thorny trees I think they hurt me before
they give me wood so I'm gonna prefer
not to chop them uh-oh Oh get away Oh
not doing good not doing good at all
things are getting a bit frozen here I'm
guessing the Hat is protecting me though
because during the night it seems that
I'm actually doing kind of okay so but
let's just warm up by the tree and fix
some more stuff oh here we go yeah the
fire is gone the fire is gone I need to
find a new place I'm getting
progressively more frozen but my hat is
doing a bid to prevent the frostbite
I've got wood so but I don't have any
stone in order to make a fire pit
ah wait no I can make the lesser fire
pit anyway just pick up food as it is
this doesn't look good everybody not
unlike you guys who look fantastic today
did I mention that did I mention how
handsome and /or pretty you look today
you're doing wonderfully keep it up
whatever you're doing it's working more
green mushroom hoes dexon we're getting
a good bit of food here I got plenty of
materials I'm actually happy because I
thought that during winter all the
bushes would go away that's what you
guys were like making it sound like I
mean obviously oh that is not a good
sign I need to make a fire like right
now I'm freezing
fire good good all right excellent
let's get that a bit more all right
we're perfectly thawed we just need to
watch that very carefully because my
help shot down a lot so let's cook some
berries because I know or eat them I
know that cooked berries and I think the
green mushrooms they give back health
I'm fairly sure I'm not positive on that
but I think they do know if they hurt me
that's not a good thing okay
cook berries and cook carrots know
what's gonna do it
I'll be fine for now I just need to make
sure that I don't get trapped in the and
the cold for long because that obviously
did me a hell of a number alright got
plenty of food out here this isn't
looking good
because I don't know how long I'll be
able to venture forward if I've only got
three hours in the day the night is very
long technically I think I need to make
a sleeping bag to get through the night
because that's what's gonna goddamn it
get the damn grass get the damn grass
there we go so I'm a mouse
for some reason it's been acting up my
mouse is not a gaming mouse right now
it's just a casual a wireless mouse and
when I play other games like Diablo that
are click fests I kind of break down the
mouse and it randomly clicks at some
points now let's sound fortunate but
heck that's the life of the gamer it's
what you take when you get so pro yeah
we're about to get night and I do not
think that I'm going to last very long
what does the divining round doing
signal is very faint okay so anyway the
divining rod what I think I've read or
from you guys is that the divining rod
helps me locate probably the portal so
that's gonna help me get to where I need
to go anyway oh it's night not a good
thing I wonder if if I make the torch
what is it a portable heat source as
well so that I can travel during the
during the night maybe hopefully I don't
know we'll find out soon enough I've got
enough to make a fire if I need to make
an emergency pit stop anyway let's just
carry on who knows what lurks in the
night you guys will protect me right you
guys have watched my back before you
guys don't tell me about anything if
there was a giant monster behind me in
this camera that you saw you wouldn't
tell me about it just to see the
reaction on my face oh what's that
it's not live how do you know it's
totally live you could totally tell me
anyway um see I don't want to unequipped
and I'm just kind of venturing out
hoping that I don't run into anything
unsavory here thing's creepy darkness a
sort of chattering of the mind chanting
of the mind that doesn't make any sense
chattering of the teeth claws in my mind
bugs crawling with in my skull blue
mustard okay it's a spider yeah yeah go
a spider I do not wish to fight you
today any other day would be lovely but
not today
was that no fireflies okay uh-huh so
dark
hey what was that I can see it's
beautiful oh I just hit a road I think I
can barely see the outline of it but I
need to get some stone so I'm gonna
hopefully find some things over here oh
god please be day it is very dark out
okay I think I see a stone up here on
the map yep
Oh righty excellent so the torch is
about to go out but I think it'll last
me before the night hits or the day hits
it's what I really need mmm Suda it's so
dark in here come on des come on damn it
damn it I need to scout out a bit more
health is not doing good this is not a
good situation to be in but I am too Pro
to die here come on des come on come on
come on I'm so scared I'm so scared
scratch robot
I'm so scared I miss Jessie okay
wouldn't in my book
here we up gotta make as much progress
during the day as possible I still don't
know what nighter is all about but I'm
gonna pick it up anyway she take the
road let's go gotta find more stone
don't know where but we gotta go we
gotta move fast as possible quick like
bunny I'm on stone d gold though I need
to quickly start upgrading my research
progress is being hindered by the
ability that wait a minute where the
snow go it went ahead oh happy day
winter has ended I survived the one
winter night that is amazing I think
winter is over huh
I must have been poured into this world
just as winter was about to end which is
oh my goodness a great sign I'm very
very happy about that
ah what a wonderful day hello rabbit ran
away screaming yeah ha ha ha I am a
gentleman a grandeur and magnification
Magnum afore connaissance it's a word
look it up
Magnum mimma Favot OU's Magnum of Papa
to the yes that's exactly what I meant
get away get away spider uh uh why so
many spiders go away
I don't want it was that a sleep Dart
what is a sleep dart do you know why
spider that's my sleep time I didn't
look a bad it's a big bird go away
spider I need to get this item on a my
inventory swell I just need it ok screw
it gimme gimme gimme
ok I got it I don't know what it does
but I'm guessing that it puts things to
sleep here's me a big tall bird I need
to go away were you singing who's ugly
you're telling just uh just uh just uh
just ah just ah yes just uh it's so good
see how I've missed you please carry my
nada how much down and please carry I
mean the divining rod oh please carry
the box and this Flint good excellent
just ah come along just saw we've got a
lot of work to do today
we need to find some goo well actually
we need to find that's I'm headed in the
right direction
am i you should well which direction am
I headed in
do you even know well I must be getting
pretty close
really I'm surprised I don't exactly
know what it picks up I don't
it's hello Tolbert no I'm not bothering
you tallbird tallbird what are these
with these rocks huh hmm getting pretty
close
hello hello hello I am still headed in
the right direction yes
wait it's getting slower uh oh no we're
back here somewhere
although what I still don't know oh this
isn't looking good need to find it
quickly
is it good up yeah no still not up here
must be down to the southwest mm-hmm
trying to get away from the spiders you
douches mm if I can find it before I
before night falls that would be great
but there's nothing over there must be
across the river like right over here I
just need to find a way around mm-hmm
damn it I'll get it eventually everybody
have faith in me do you have faith makes
you believe in me like I believe in you
damn it where the hell whoa Oh
walrus camp Oh minore look at these
things be for those I finally found some
me blows now don't worry about me I
won't kill you but I will stay near you
to pick up your pouf it's perfectly
normal
I'm not stains you shut up I just want
your poop what are you talking about
that's perfectly normal
yeah yeah okay anyway I'm gonna make a
camp right here and I'm gonna end the
episode here so we're in a good
situation we got the divining run that's
telling us something as close I imagine
it's right over here somewhere cuz I can
see a huge land mass I owe I went the
wrong way didn't I I bet I could have
hat okay anyway so it's right over there
I've made a long way since I started it
right up there but we're very close it's
over here ish know without a doubt in my
mind I just need to get there so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh
No
though
No
ah